you know when you ask what is crypto you
can either have a very complicated
explanation or you can have a relatively
simple explanation
i'm gonna go simple
crypto at the most basic level
is a code
it's a set of numbers
and if you look at any dollar bill or
any piece of paper currency that we have
in the united states what you'll do is
you'll see a number a serial number on
that dollar bill
i have here with me l30407317l
now imagine a world
where if i wanted to spend a dollar i
didn't give you this piece of paper
but instead what i did
is i told you that code i just go up to
you and i say to you
l30407317l
the value of the dollar then goes to you
and the number then changes
i forget that number or the number that
i had in the past
is no longer useful
i've then transferred the code to you
and the fact that the code happens to be
written on this piece of paper is
totally irrelevant
the value is the code not the piece of
paper
that's crypto
in the world of crypto the code is much
longer the code is much more complicated
the code is much harder to remember
but it's still only code
if you forget your code
you've lost your crypto
if somebody steals your code your crypto
has been stolen
now
as a practical matter in many systems
this code this number and the value
represented by the code exists on
something that we call the blockchain
the blockchain can be described as a
giant giant giant database
that exists in thousands or potentially
millions of places on the internet
and that has what's called an immutable
audit trail
in other words you can read the history
of the blockchain simply by reading that
database
and because copies of that database
exist
in thousands hundreds of thousands or
millions of different locations
it becomes as a practical matter
impossible to cheat as to who owns what
when where and how because millions of
people are able to look at the database
and say aha you don't own that or yes
you do
there's also a process by which this
database gets updated and this process
is typically called mining
it involves complicated computerized
forms of hashing other forms of
validation the mathematics can get
extraordinarily complicated but what it
boils down to as a practical matter is
there are a bunch of specialist
computers that wind up looking at
changes to the blockchain and then
validating the fact that that change
actually has occurred and some token or
some value or some crypto whatever it is
has moved from one place on the
blockchain to another
in order to make changes on the
blockchain you typically need to
validate the fact that some crypto has
moved from one location to another
that process is often done with the
intervention of miners
miners typically run computerized
operations where they perform very
complicated mathematical functions which
are designed to assure the integrity of
the system and that people aren't double
spending any of their money and that the
transactions that are supposed to occur
are actually recorded appropriately and
permanently on the blockchain